well a stream beyond YouTube only if
it's YouTube worthy I'm becoming more
and more selective with YouTube contents
want to make sure it's quality Hey okay
playing alpha move good luck
yeah I feel like three minute is much
more popular than than five plus three
so I guess it's nice running a 5 plus a
tournament cuz he's got to enjoy some
longer blitz opponent plays each six so
each six kind of prevents black from
castling Oh probably wants to play this
I've had this before so I kind of lose a
bishop pair but I have very nice
developments I files open probably
should have played the other rook and
then each four ideas
[Music]
I really want to put them out on f5 the
problem with 93 is takes takes takes
it's kind of a pong sack it's
interesting I don't know each pawn move
is this move it's kind of a cool move
Knights just chilling in the center idea
would be c3 so now I'm reinforcing upon
the night might get stuck here if blacks
on how gets in c6 yeah maybe it's not so
bad Bishop d3 c6 Knight before don't
hurt me
I do not have a photographic memory but
[Music]
I am capable of remembering photographs
[Music]
play this move hmm hey it's checkmate
checkmate Kate's saying I watched out
for ads for these probably referring to
the bits cuz yeah you can watch ads and
get a select number of bits thanks for
that hmm
I should probably take first and then
this move it's a nice house
and c4 yeah very nice outpost and then
I'll have two nice outposts
that's not bad Bishop okay I'm happy
here
I think actually this this pawn on e3 is
very useful because it prevents a knight
from actually achieving any outposts and
probably each for ideas the goal is to
open one of the files if not both and
yeah we could trade Knights
oh it's for the rook here hey pawns are
doing some some y action the King's
gonna excavate itself we want to start
with this and then this and then this a
bishop so sad and rookie seven coming
I'm not winning yet though but it's so
nice what's my plan actually black might
be in subs long eventually what is black
gonna do because the Queen can't oh the
king can move hmm is this crazy move
just a huge clump of pieces to watch out
for time my King maybe wants to enter
was the King doing what's my plan
clocks really tied down though and then
put thinking on G for the rook oh I have
a plan I have a nice plan
Bishop h5 I'm gonna wait until the King
moves here and then play this yeah now
the rooks attack the rooks also tied
down to the bishop yeah so this just
winds
that's a cool position I had like
unlimited time it's still not over
though play this and win a pawn yeah I
had time to like get the optimal setup
the King can be useful like defending
the bishop in some cases okay forget I
have Queen here
[Music]
okay that was nice it was a nice kind of
positional game a very unusual like for
the whole standard to be clothes
infiltration happened on the kingside
but I had to make my my bishop come to
life nice maneuver